Metoda kwantowej diagonalizacji opartej na próbkowaniu, w skrócie SQD, to kwantowo-klasyczny algorytm hybrydowy, podobnie jak Krylov
kwantowa diagonalizacja KQD, VQE i wiele innych. Korzystając z takich hybrydowych
algorytmów, warto zastanowić się, gdzie każdy z nich wykorzystuje obliczenia kwantowe i klasyczne. Przypomnij sobie, że VQE tworzy stany na
circuit za pomocą klasycznie zoptymalizowanych parametrów. W tym przypadku sam stan jest na komputerze kwantowym, choć
uzyskanie stanu docelowego to proces łączący zarówno obliczenia klasyczne, jak i kwantowe.
Wartość oczekiwana operatora jest obliczana za pomocą pomiarów kwantowych.
Konieczne jest jednak również pewne klasyczne łączenie wyrazów.
W przeciwieństwie do tego, SQD używa komputera kwantowego do wygenerowania użytecznej podprzestrzeni, na którą można rzutować Hamiltonian lub inny operator.
Hamiltonian jest następnie diagonalizowany w całości klasycznie, aby znaleźć stan docelowy. Załóżmy, że mamy
problem ważny dla nauki lub przemysłu, który można sformułować jako zadanie eigensolwera na macierzy o n wierszach i
n kolumnach. Załóżmy dalej, że n jest na tyle duże, że dokładna klasyczna diagonalizacja nie wchodzi w grę.
Byłoby oczywiście korzystne zredukować wymiary naszej macierzy, zachowując jednocześnie wszystkie istotne cechy stanu podstawowego. Właśnie to jest
celem wielu przybliżonych metod eigensolwera, w tym klasycznych metod Kryłowa. Załóżmy, że wiemy wystarczająco dużo o naszym problemie, by
poczynić całkiem dobre przypuszczenie co do postaci stanu podstawowego, ale niewystarczająco dużo, by rozwiązać problem od razu.
W takim przypadku moglibyśmy wielokrotnie mierzyć nasze dobre przybliżenie docelowego stanu podstawowego. Wyniki tych
pomiarów dają nam podprzestrzeń obliczeniowych stanów bazowych zawierającą wszystkie istotne składowe naszego
stanu podstawowego. Rzutowanie na tę podprzestrzeń dałoby mniejszą macierz, która nadal zawiera istotne stopnie
swobody. Przepływ pracy wygląda następująco. Zaczynasz od wybrania dobrego
ansatzu. Mówiąc ściślej, wybierz ansatz, którego nośnik pokrywa się z nośnikiem stanu docelowego. Omówimy dokładnie, co
to oznacza. Następnie zmierz stan w obliczeniowej bazie, tak jak to się robi z prymitywem sampler.
Potem użyj wyników próbkowania, aby zdefiniować podprzestrzeń zawierającą stan podstawowy.
Następnie rzutuj swoją macierz na tę podprzestrzeń. Na koniec diagonalizuj mniejszą rzutowaną macierz klasycznie.
Przeanalizujmy każdy z tych kroków, zwracając szczególną uwagę na definiowanie podprzestrzeni.
W całym quantum computingu wybór dobrego ansatzu jest zawsze kluczowy. W przypadku SQD twój wybór ansatzu
określa, jakie obliczeniowe stany bazowe mogą zostać zmierzone podczas próbkowania.
Prawdziwy stan podstawowy można wyrazić jako superpozycję pewnego podzbioru obliczeniowych stanów bazowych. Ten podzbiór
nazywamy nośnikiem stanu podstawowego. Aby uzyskać dobre oszacowanie stanu podstawowego i jego energii, twój ansatz
musi mieć niezerowe rzutowanie na obliczeniowe stany bazowe należące do nośnika stanu podstawowego.
Ten diagram przedstawia przestrzeń rozpiętą przez wszystkie możliwe stany na używanej liczbie qubitów. Chcemy
ansatzu, którego nośnik zawiera nośnik prawdziwego stanu podstawowego.
Rozważmy bardzo mały przykładowy układ ze stanem podstawowym s_ground = 8 *
stan 1 0 0 plus 6 * stan 001.
Ma on nośnik złożony z dwóch wektorów 1 0 0 i 0 1. Powiedzmy, że ansatz ma postać ANSATZ 1 równy A razy
stan 1 0 0 plus B * stan 0 1 0 plus C * stan 001. Tak że jego
nośnik to zbiór trzech wektorów 1 0 0, 1 0 i 0 0 1 – nadzbiór
nośnika stanu podstawowego. To jest dobry ansatz.
Wyobraź sobie teraz, że zamiast tego wybralibyśmy ansatz postaci ANSATZ 2 = a *
stan 1 1 0 plus b * stan 011.
Ma on nośnik złożony z dwóch wektorów 11 1 0 i 011, który nie ma żadnego przecięcia z nośnikiem stanu
podstawowego. To jest zły ansatz.
Zwróć uwagę, że niekoniecznie wymagamy, aby ansatz był dobrym przybliżeniem stanu podstawowego. Ansatz może
mieć znacznie większy nośnik lub współczynniki mogą być bardzo różne w ansatzu i prawdziwym stanie podstawowym i nadal działać dobrze.
Na tym etapie użyliśmy dobrze umotywowanego ansatzu, by komputer kwantowy przyjął stan podobny do naszego stanu docelowego.
Pokazany tutaj jest unitarny sprzężony gastro, czyli ansatz UCJ, bardzo przydatny w chemii kwantowej.
Chcemy teraz zmierzyć stan układu, uzyskując bitstrings opisujące stan skolapsowany każdego
qubitu. Przypomnij sobie, że estymacja Hamiltonianu, tak jak w VQE, wymaga wielu pomiarów kwantowych. Wynika to częściowo z
konieczności redukcji niepewności, a częściowo z liczby grup komutujących operatorów Pauliego składających się na Hamiltonian.
W metodach próbkowania nadal potrzeba wielu pomiarów, ale z innych powodów. Teraz potrzebujemy wielu pomiarów, aby skutecznie próbkować
wiele obliczeniowych stanów bazowych związanych z silnie splątanymi stanami kwantowymi. W SQD próbkowane bitstrings odpowiadają
konfiguracjom symulowanego układu. Jeśli badany układ podlega bezwzględnym ograniczeniom, takim jak
prawa zachowania w fizyce lub chemii, większość zmierzonych stanów będzie prawidłowa. Jednak część próbkowanych
bitstrings odpowiada nieprawidłowym lub niefizycznym konfiguracjom ze względu na szum i błędy. Proces zwany
odzyskiwaniem konfiguracji ma na celu udoskonalenie tych zaszumionych próbek w zestaw dokładniejszych konfiguracji.
Proces ten polega na generowaniu nowych konfiguracji przez probabilistyczne odwracanie poszczególnych bitów na podstawie
uśrednionych obsadzeń orbitali i znanych liczb cząstek.
Dopracowane konfiguracje są następnie używane do rozpiącia podprzestrzeni dla rzutowania i diagonalizacji Hamiltonianu,
iteracyjnie poprawiając wierność reprezentacji stanu kwantowego.
Przyjrzyjmy się trywialnie małemu przykładowi odzyskiwania konfiguracji, aby zrozumieć jego sens. Załóżmy, że mierzymy
układ kwantowy z czterema qubitami reprezentującymi cztery orbitale molekularne i uzyskujemy następujące bitstrings z
procesora kwantowego. Każdy bitstring reprezentuje obsadzenie orbitalu. Jeden oznacza
obsadzone, zero oznacza nieobsadzone. Qiskit używa notacji, w której najmniej znaczący qubit jest po prawej stronie.
Na przykład 1 0 1 0 oznacza, że orbitale 1 i trzy są obsadzone. Te
pomiary zostały dobrane wyłącznie w celach dydaktycznych. Wynikające z nich obsadzenia mogą nie odpowiadać układowi fizycznemu. W kontekstach fizycznych
często zdarza się, że układ ma znaną całkowitą liczbę cząstek. Mogą też istnieć inne prawa zachowania,
które można wykorzystać do określenia fizyczności zmierzonego stanu. Aby być konkretnym, załóżmy, że nasz układ ma
znana całkowitą liczbę cząstek n = 2. Mówi nam to o całkowitej liczbie jedynek, która powinna pojawić się w naszej etykiecie stanu –
co nazywamy ograniczeniem wagi Hamminga.
Jednak niektóre zmierzone konfiguracje naruszają to ograniczenie. Stan 1 0 1 0 jest fizycznie prawidłowy. Ale stan 1 1
1 0 ma za dużo cząstek, a stan samych zer ma ich za mało. Zero
właściwie. Te naruszenia mogą wynikać z szumu w układzie lub błędów pomiaru. Potrzebujemy sposobu, by wrócić
do konfiguracji, które mają sens fizyczny – przynajmniej w sposób przybliżony.
Nazywa się to odzyskiwaniem konfiguracji.
Aby skorygować nasze zaszumione próbki, probabilistycznie odwracamy bity w nieprawidłowych konfiguracjach na podstawie średniego
obsadzenia orbitali uśrednionego po prawidłowych konfiguracjach.
Obsadzenia orbitali to wartości oczekiwane operatora liczby działającego na każdy orbital. Jest to estymowane i
doskonalone samokonsekwentnie przy użyciu stanów produkowanych przez SQD. Przyjrzyjmy się na przykład orbitalowi 2. W dwóch z
czterech prawidłowych konfiguracji orbital 2 był obsadzony. Daje nam to oczekiwane obsadzenie równe 0,5.
Robimy to samo dla pozostałych trzech orbitali. Teraz wracamy do nieprawidłowej konfiguracji 1 1 0. Możemy odwrócić jeden z
bitów z 1 na zero, aby uzyskać prawidłową konfigurację. Ale który powinniśmy odwrócić? Jednym ze sposobów decydowania jest
odchylenie obsadzenia każdego orbitalu od obliczonych przez nas średnich.
Widzimy tutaj, że największa różnica dotyczy obsadzenia orbitalu pierwszego. Można więc oczekiwać, że bit pierwszy powinien zostać
odwrócony z jedynki na zero. Oczywiście orbital 2 nie jest daleko w tyle. I zawsze jest możliwe, choć mało prawdopodobne, że
ten zmierzony stan jest wynikiem wielokrotnych błędów na tym samym stanie.
Wybieranie tylko największego odchylenia od średniej dla wszystkich nieprawidłowych stanów nie jest optymalne. Zamiast tego bity są odwracane
probabilistycznie, przy czym prawdopodobieństwo jest funkcją pokazanych tu różnic. Załóżmy, że w tym
przypadku zmieniamy bit, który najbardziej odbiega od średniego obsadzenia. Czyli 1 1 0 staje się 1 1 0 0. Robimy to samo
dla innego nieprawidłowego wyboru. Powiedzmy, że tym razem odwracamy bity pierwszy i trzeci.
Po tym procesie korekcji mamy nowy zestaw konfiguracji, który może wyglądać tak.
Korzystając z tego dopracowanego zestawu, możemy zaktualizować średnie obsadzenie orbitali, aby poprawić wierność. W naszym przypadku nowe
obsadzenia są następujące.
Ten iteracyjny proces odzyskiwania zapewnia filtrowanie zaszumionych pomiarów do fizycznie sensownych
konfiguracji, poprawiając dokładność przybliżeń eigenstanów w SQD. Dodatek Qiskit do SQD ma narzędzia,
które będą nieocenione w tym procesie. Jeśli dobrze próbkowaliśmy stany należące do nośnika prawdziwego stanu podstawowego
układu, powinniśmy być w stanie skupić się tylko na tych częściach Hamiltonianu, które działają na tę podprzestrzeń,
i nadal uzyskać dobry stan podstawowy i energię. W naszym trywialnie małym przykładzie z 4 qubitami początkowo mamy 2 lub 16
możliwych stanów układu. Używając kombinacji próbkowania i odzyskiwania konfiguracji, redukujemy to
do trzech stanów w naszej podprzestrzeni zainteresowania – trzech stanów, które mamy nadzieję tworzą nośnik prawdziwego stanu podstawowego.
Rzutujemy teraz nasz pełny Hamiltonian na tę podprzestrzeń. Tzn. tworzymy macierz M z kolumny wektorów z naszej
odzyskanej podprzestrzeni próbkowania i analogiczną M dagger z wierszy, i mnożymy M dagger HM
obrazowo. Oznacza to wzięcie elementów macierzowych w wierszach i kolumnach odpowiadających stanom z naszej
odzyskanej podprzestrzeni próbkowania. Wyróżnione wiersze i kolumny to te odpowiadające naszej podprzestrzeni, a
ciemniejsze wyróżnione pola w miejscach ich przecięcia to elementy, które zachowujemy dla naszej nowej rzutowanej macierzy.
Teraz, gdy wybraliśmy interesującą nas podprzestrzeń, możemy diagonalizować tę macierz na komputerze klasycznym
za pomocą standardowego solwera. Jeśli prawdziwy stan podstawowy składa się w całości ze stanów z naszej podprzestrzeni,
diagonalizacja powinna dać poprawny stan podstawowy i energię stanu podstawowego. Jeśli posiadamy większość nośnika stanu podstawowego,
możemy uzyskać wynik zbliżony. Po uzyskaniu stanu podstawowego dla tego rzutowanego Hamiltonianu mamy bardzo
użyteczny stan, z którego możemy obliczyć średnie obsadzenie każdego orbitalu.
Wcześniej nasze obsadzenia były obliczane ze stanów, które próbkowaliśmy za pomocą ansatzu, który miał nam pomóc
zbliżyć się do stanu podstawowego. Nie było jednak gwarancji, że średnie obsadzenie każdego orbitalu z tego próbkowania odpowiadało obsadzeniu
w stanie o najniższej energii. Cofnijmy się. Mieliśmy próbkowanie stanów obliczeniowych. Użyliśmy odzyskiwania konfiguracji,
aby poprawić te fizycznie nieprawidłowe. Następnie obliczyliśmy średnie obsadzenie orbitali używając wszystkich z nich.
Stan podstawowy może obejmować tylko część z nich. Stan podstawowy tego rzutowanego Hamiltonianu może nie być prawdziwym stanem podstawowym
naszego pierwotnego układu, ale jest stanem o najniższej energii, który można stworzyć za pomocą dowolnej superpozycji
odzyskanych stanów z naszej podprzestrzeni. Obsadzenie orbitali tego stanu da energię mniejszą lub równą
energii obsadzenia uzyskanego z odzyskanej przestrzeni. Zatem to obsadzenie jest lepszym oszacowaniem naszego
obsadzenia stanu podstawowego. Możemy powtórzyć proces odzyskiwania konfiguracji używając tego nowego obsadzenia i możemy iterować
tak długo, aż zostaną spełnione nasze kryteria zbieżności. Kwantowa diagonalizacja oparta na próbkowaniu jest szybka w porównaniu z
innymi algorytmami nieodległej przyszłości, takimi jak VQE. Jest bardziej skalowalna i odporna na szum i błędy próbkowania.
Nadal wymaga przygotowania dobrego ansatzu z dużym rzutowaniem na nośnik prawdziwego stanu podstawowego naszego układu. Jeśli nic nie jest znane
o naszym prawdziwym stanie podstawowym, SQD może wymagać użycia w połączeniu z innymi metodami, aby najpierw poznać
stan podstawowy i iteracyjnie do niego dążyć.
SQD odgrywa kluczową rolę w rozwijającym się zestawie klasyczno-kwantowych algorytmów hybrydowych i jest jednym z
największych motorów napędowych w kierunku użytecznych obliczeń kwantowych.